ukraine's former president petro
poroshenko has returned to his country
after a month abroad he faces charges of
high treason and is under investigation
many of his assets have already been
seized but he is returning in his words
to fight russian aggression against
ukraine poroshenko says he wants to work
with the current government to prevent a
possible invasion
we can speak now to our kia bureau chief
matthias bilinga standing by for us hi
matthias tell us what has been happening
today
so poroshenko has arrived at the airport
here in kikkiv in the morning
and he
has addressed his fans at the airport
then he drove to court there was a court
hearing that began at 11 o'clock so an
hour ago he is now in court in front of
the court he again addressed his his
followers his fans who had gathered
there and who are still standing there
and meeting there
[Music]
he has said basically that he has
returned to work together with the
current government
facing this crisis uh the russian
troop build up at the border but uh his
his critics accuse him of using the
situation to gain to make some personal
gains in this in this critical situation
for the country and and setting himself
as as
as a hero in this situation he has been
simone to court a month ago when he was
outside of the country and he missed
that hearing uh now this hearing today
has been scheduled before and he has
announced that he would return
and
we will see what comes out in this court
hearing will be decided whether he'll
remain in custody or walk free possibly
on bail but yes give us some background
on pedro poroshenko and why his return
now is so significant
pedro poroshenko
was the first elected president after
the maidan after the revolution here in
kiev in 2013 so in 2015 he assumed the
presidency when the country was under
attack crimea had been seized by russia
and the donbass uh was uh was was
ruled by the separatists with russian
support so uh he has basically been the
president that has uh been sitting over
this over this escalation and over this
war and who has been able his
supporters and some critics say to build
up somehow uh
a military uh infrastructure here in the
country um but he was he was defeated uh
significantly badly in the in in the
last election uh when uh zelensky a
former comedian who had no prior
experience in politics uh won a
landslide victory people had been
discontent with uh
poroshenko's achievements economically
and also in terms of reform
anti-corruption
now he comes back at a point where the
country is again under attack with this
russian military buildup and where
people are again unhappy with their
president because zlatan as well has not
delivered so far what many people have
expected um so the the next elections
will be in two years and this seems to
be the beginning of a power struggle
between these two men uh if no other
person shows up in this in this battle
until then and matthias the german
foreign minister annalena bearbach is
also in kiev today what can we expect
from her meetings
well the most important thing is that
she stopped in kiev before heading to
moscow this is a strong signal to moscow
that germany supports ukraine however
ukraine is not happy with the way
germany supports germany blocks until
now any delivery of defensive weapons to
ukraine directly from germany or from
other countries where germany has a say
this is for example buying from nato or
from other countries who have tr who
want to resell weaponry that was built
in germany to ukraine and that germany
is blocking right now this would be
probably one of the most important
things the two governments would discuss
the foreign ministers
but it's unlikely that there will be any
outcome today archaea bureau chief
matthias billinger there reporting thank
you